[ __ ] god dammit hi how are you doing
good to see you here I didn't notice you
there at first but I just wanted to say
thanks for stopping by
I'm not quite done farming yet but I'll
be with you in just a moment you can
watch while I work you beautiful people
and totally ignore the fact that I just
got spooked by a warp stash over there
hey buddy how you doing it seems like
every time I say the word warp stash you
pop in and out of existence like an
a-hole that's a lot of soul looks like
this guy has lost salt about his
dumbness yeah got him roasted him good
welcome although these are wonderfully
charged I do appreciate you being so
studious in their level of charge
those are doing whoa those are doing
well let me I'll leave that one in a
boink boink and now that could 891 very
good I know I am tied for who is my
silver you and my quartz give you the
quartz Oh full of quartz heck oh yeah
yeah man that'll that unlimited energy
thing is that's real handy that is I am
NOT gonna lie I am totally okay with
doing that 100% because my god that
makes my life easy where oh where is
there more silver
oh I see you below me whoo hey how you
doing there friend Oh didn't know that
this was your territory hope you don't
mind if you uh [ __ ] off and die that's
an option just wanted to throw that out
there you're not gonna stop me from
getting my silver not today not today
yeah trying get me try big box bear is
gonna fudge you up mother humper I
showed him oh hey whoa
alright then that was close for comfort
I don't feel safe and many of you may
know whether I'm actually in danger or
not but you doesn't seem too interested
alright well alright I'm gonna go for it
hey come at me bro
come at me don't come at me do not come
at me oh don't come at me a little more
little little oh that's close for
comfort okay oh my go I'm gonna go now
hey oh [ __ ] I missed well that was close
think I somehow got out of a box Kinema
tits yeah my razor steel nips well I
think I screamed like a little bitty but
that's okay because you know happens
anyway I almost cried but that's all
good maybe I can Ram them it doesn't
seem like the Cyclops gets any dents
anymore well there's more silver but
again I don't know if that's safe for me
to get maybe if I stay with him all that
that one looks plowing looks much more
friendly to get now it looks much
friendlier alright I likey this one this
one's a plus in my book now let's hope I
don't die here we go Klan
target seems safe question mark
alright here we go silver silver silver
I love lots of silver silver silver
silver' hope I don't die now silver
silver silver in my body silver I love
you silver silver silver' obeying up
your dog now silver silver silver'
charge on my goddamn chauffeured silver
silver oh yeah we're good now I weren't
dead not not I wish I were dead thats
debby said over silver silver opal up to
baby
[ __ ] you okay welcome back to subnautica
sorry about the slightly jarring opening
but I am now ready to go towards this
precursor cash and not only that I know
exactly where it is and I know exactly
how to find it but first
Corky Lu who said so as Marc's children
Geoffrey Billy samurais and Marshall
made big bucks Barry and then big box
Barry and the reef back made Jeremy or
blue or whatever his name is does that
mean mark is a great grandfather yay
congrats mark I suppose that does
oddly enough it has a little bit of
incestuous connotations with it with
Geoffrey Billy ceramides Marshall but
I'm not over looking at considering
there's absolutely no one else here and
they're all robots anyway so it's all
just I can overlook that love is love
and then uh pokey maniac Chris who said
is it just me
who wants Marc to scan the reefer
Leviathan
it's a sadistic thing that you want I
can try I'll try for you I get Emilien
I'm not even going to put it up I'm
gonna do it as soon as I get done with
the comments but you may be looking like
Oh only two lockers this time Marc what
what's going on darling three Oh hold
your horses I've got another locker over
here in the naughty corner and you can
see it right there and you should know
that this person deserves this um mr.
con master 10:12 what were you even
thinking I should have known
by your name that you were up to no good
and I'm not talking like marauders map
no good I'm talking like blow up the
Aurora and destroy all my friends and
family no good
you said you should name your seamoth
puny package patty well how dare you mr.
or mrs. I don't really know and I don't
want to assume anything Kahn master how
could you think about what you've done
in your corner as I try to scan a Reaper
Leviathan which is probably a bad idea
but then again I've had bad ideas before
and this probably won't be the last
so you think about what you do have done
as I rush up to meet certain doom in the
hands of this particular reboot I've
covered for you hey you want to you want
you want dosey doe buddy you want dosey
doe long oh oh
get rekt wretch hey where'd you go man
where'd you go reap II we provided
Reaper there's this here I was gonna
knock it you know give it a little love
nudge with my big box berry here but it
seems to have skedaddle depressed
it doesn't just disappear does it what a
hack you just disappeared
did the warper warp it away can it do
that well that's peculiar and you are
playing out a game of chicken there
buddy oh come on what you got oh what's
that
oh no don't hit me with your big bucks
dick oh no well I guess that's not a
problem
haha well I don't see him anymore he
seems to be down let me just go get this
piece of titanium because I want it
alright don't see it very scary I don't
see it let's go get this other piece of
titanium alone in the ocean not scared
at all alrighty then
I thought I was going to try to scan a
reaper Leviathan but that doesn't seem
to be in the card so I found out how to
do the coordinates thing so the
coordinates to the doones alien
precursor cache is negative eleven
eighty seven negative 378 and eleven
thirty which all count to XY and z
coordinates so one being the depth down
one being lateral one being longitudinal
and you find your coordinate by pressing
s1 and then I'll bring up this debug
menu not a cheap menu it'll bring up a
menu that will allow you to know where
your position is if you look at the
camera world position somewhere in the
upper middle area that you'll see a set
of three numbers so I'm looking for 1187
on the first one which means I'm pretty
close to that I just got to go this way
a bit and then 378 which I'm assuming
means 378 down and then 1130 so that's
the distance that I got to travel the
most which is forward and I'm thinking
that it's on the other side of this like
mushroom force it said it was in a
crater now if I think back I think I
remember seeing a crater somewhere here
so I'm going to take that information
and I'm going to go to where I think the
crater is because there's an entrance to
the inactive lava zone here but there's
also a crater that I found a long time
ago that didn't seem to do anything now
if that's the one that they're talking
about that means they put something new
there and that I can find it because
I've got a purple alien key and I'm
going to stick it in any purple slot
that I see
all right okay so head it down a bit
just a digit justice squeeze just to
squeeze cuz I got to get down to
negative 378 so this must go down at
some point it looks like that point is
no this the void isn't it who this is
this is quite a void he's done it
setting I couldn't tell hmm oh there we
go
well I came out of nowhere oh is this is
this it actually we're just just the
edge of everything that I know and love
and care about because I can't see [ __ ]
except for something glowing over there
I don't know what that is what the heck
are you oh oh oh that looks like an
entrance to some sort of precursor thing
oh snap I can't see jack [ __ ] but I can
see you okay so I'm gonna Nestle Nestle
my big box berry right next to this
ominous looking cave that looks like a
mouth with peace in it and I'ma save and
then I'm gonna eat some fruit now I'm
gonna get the fudge out of here Dora did
that scare off the Predators loud noises
do that or whatever I probably I don't
know num num num okay that'll be enough
for now and then I got some water over
here okay I just drank water what is
your problem okay I'm gonna put this
away here going to weak
I don't need to silver with me but I
want to keep it with me just cuz I feel
like it okay alright whatever yeah do
you think about what you've done Khan
master or should I check I see clops or
should I just go in hand and foot good I
guess I could take this huh come give it
to me Oh shove me right in there up
through the butthole I'm gonna take mr.
Fisher but I'm gonna abandon it as soon
as I can because I just don't want to
deal with this [ __ ] wait thanks woo
oh this is weird okay buhdeuce
brueski okay all right here okay I'll
grab some acid mushrooms on the way out
because I need a drug trip in addition
to what the hell hole I'm going into do
I hear the etheral glowing of the
do or oh I do oh is that a purple slot
I'm gonna shove something in there I got
you covered buddy yeah take that rewind
it back I got the beat the maker Pootie
go smack whatever it is that's a Reaper
all right you can't get me in this cave
buddy boo
I can barely fit in this cave well maybe
I can't go any further just like ah
shoot okay can't go any further than
this so I hope there's uh Oh what is
this okay oh I on crystal thank you
thank you
untold energy in the palm of my hand huh
thank you thank you whoa give me your
data alien biological history unlocked
well good cool I think anyway one num
num num num num num num okay all right I
guess that's all I needed holy hell for
ion crystals
was that it I mean let me look at the
data first before I just like David all
right
that guy's angry up there stop humping
big bug Barry he's taken this terminal
contains data mapping the complete
biological history of a member of the
alien species the data set is hugely
complex but basic facts can be
reconstructed was grown from seed 1708
birth years ago separated from brood
Ling's early for special training
inducted in the temple of research as
the youngest ever initiate age 96
downloaded a corrupt data set and was
stored for three years for refactoring
relocated to the outer galaxy cluster to
support disease research endeavors
relocated to for five for six B for
high-priority disease research
contracted Cora bacterium steward in
sanctuary 3 corporeal body safely
disposed
that's interesting
grown from seed separated from brutal
install a training so this is talking
about one of the precursors and there's
interesting stuff here because obviously
their brains work in the way the
computers do in that it can download
data and it downloaded a corrupted data
set but their physical bodies are still
biological in design I guess so it's
either a hybrid of Juche it's either a
hybrid oh no oh that's the way I look
ups it's either a hybrid of some sort or
it's technology to look like develop to
the point where something can you know
just interface with the brain and they
can download information as they wish
which is cool but that that raises so
many more questions that gives some
interesting information okay sorry
okay I'll skedaddle I want the safety of
big-box berries bosoms give it to me
okay but that also raises some
interesting questions as to who these
aliens are what does that mean for like
the entirety of their society if their
children or their useful tools are grown
from seed in big batches and relocated
as needed do they have free will is this
like a thing where it's just hey do what
you're told until you die and then your
body's disposed but then it said
corporeal body which a pretty sure that
means the physical body but maybe the
consciousness was downloaded or uploaded
into the computer system answers
fascinating it was stored for eight
years and obviously these things have
long lifespans if the earliest
initiative was 96 earth years old and
considering this was 1700 years ago that
it was born or grown from seed then that
could mean
it it contracted karar only recently and
that would be very interesting okay
hello but either way I did what I set
out to accomplish which is good because
I have silver and I have quartz and I've
got a lot a lot of materials to work
with here the only thing I don't have is
a lot of titanium but I can grab that on
the way back now I need to go back to my
main base down below because now I have
enough material and I have my Kitty
poster to keep me company but I have
enough material to go deep down in to
the inactive lava zone and see what
really lies down in the deep part of the
ocean that terrifies me so and I'm
pretty sure I can fit my big box buried
down the way in the grand reef but I'm
not a hundred ceinture so this might be
a wild adventure where I try to squeeze
big buck burying holes that he shouldn't
fit in but I'm gonna try my best and see
where that gets me from here too bad I
couldn't scan that River Leviathan you
know I'm really broken up about that oh
well c'est la vie ooh copper silver I've
got enough bu but I need me some copper
I need me some strange Silver's young
fan I am a Roman I'm a Roman soul
survivor of a rack and have no actual
friends so I got a personify a giant
mineral or an element who shares where
you are but coppers words that baby
coppers words hot it just it just gets
me you know I can poon it whenever I
want
harpoon I mean yeah you know what I'm
talking about right what I don't know
I'm trying to create a love triangle
with silver and copper and I think
you're going crazy I think I might
actually be going crazy yeah I'm pretty
sure I'm going crazy yeah 100 I'm going
crazy yeah all right so now what I need
to do is I need to get back to my base
and maybe drop off some of this copper
and such in their silver starting to
stack up so was ready or so was silver
now and just a little bit of ion crystal
have bad
yeah alright so I need some table chloro
before I go all the way back I need to
cut up a bunch of table coral and then I
should be good to go down and then I
don't think I don't think I'm gonna need
any more materials to get what I need to
get to be able to get where I need to go
I'm pretty sure not a hundred percent
not a hundred percent but pretty sure I
think maybe not a hundred percent
mo titanium well there's there's normal
coral I can at least get some of that so
I can make some more water
I don't know why I spend so much time
like building a water filtration thing
that drains a million tons of power when
I could literally just a common Coral
all day long and then get all the
possible water I need out of all the
salt I have which salt is so plentiful
why would I even bother trying to go
anywhere else for it okay
so I'm literally just gonna carry a
whole mess for this common Coral
and then get table coral as it go and
then live my life you know just be free
feel the world around me steal it I've
been in the ocean long enough that I've
started to realize that maybe we're not
so different after all
maybe I shouldn't have been so scared
maybe just maybe this ocean loves me and
wants to accept me for who I am and you
know maybe just maybe if I find solace
in the fact that we're not so different
maybe I can learn to love it maybe I can
learn to even respect it you know
there's something to be said about that
oh right that's a little bit odd now
we're starting to stock up I'm starting
to actually use these lockers which is
something that I never really did before
okay so the last thing that I need
before I leave this episode is I need to
find me some table coral because once I
got that there's no stopping me I've got
everything I could possibly
for and this looks like where there
would be table coral but it's not there
peculiar well the table color oh they're
all you there are all of you who are you
- they kill each and every one of you up
here your whole family IQ all your coral
mites
I'll kill them all a yearling the other
gonna see coming now you ain't never
gonna see it coming eh ah you thought
you feel Skype huh you thought you can
run ah
no from me not for long I always give me
pray and speaking a Prai I'm gonna
prayed for more power cuz that's what on
me and you gotta be some table coral
round I see you oh I struck the mother
lode a chicken a stricken mother
building I'm gonna take all of you I'm
never gonna run out of coral again as I
scream into the distance Carl I know I
know I know she hush now it's okay
you're home you're home with me
that is a lot of table coral I don't
still get more cuz I got space to fill
in my inventory and I've got space to
fill in my big box Barry oh yes oh yes
oh yes I'm good
oh yes alright catchy row you're gonna
get a whole bunch table coral but I'm
gonna keep some of you because I'm about
to make some stuff and I need you to be
right here with me by my side where's
all the silver and there you thought you
could hide from me
now you can I'm about to make wiring kit
I do any courts oopsies oh yes computer
chip finally I knew
I knew I knew you wouldn't run from me
this time alright so what do I need to
make that other battery charger titanium
and then for the other one copper wire
where did I put that copper I don't know
where anything is here alright so can I
make another yes I can okay so that
means I've got two computer chips and
now I just need a wiring kit and so with
that I've got everything I need to make
a second one of these battery churches
and the only benefit to this is that it
allows me to charge twice you know at a
time and I'll make that lololo okay I'm
gonna take that back here wait and we're
gonna redo this I'm gonna pull them all
again on this one it's gonna make it a
little little higher a little higher
there that's that stuff so now that I've
got bad put those bad boys in there and
then those bad boys are gonna be
charging up all day long they're gonna
nothin stop me and also I think I can
make all the glasses glass and just like
that shabu Ski now this one is not
self-sustaining it's not the same as the
Power Cell of ones it is going to take a
lot more power but the benefit of this
is I will have battery charger here so
that I don't have to constantly be
making them if I wanted to I could take
my seam off and go grab all the dead
batteries from my other base way over
yonder way but at least I have it don't
mind that it's pitch black which is kind
of Kanade well I don't mind looks
stealthy I like it so with that being
said I'm all out of time for this
episode I can make my way back to my
base in the grand reef and then venture
down deep into the inactive lava zone go
down the ghost River a Lost River might
as well be the ghost River and see what
finally lies down lurking deep below I'm
having a lot of fun with this I love
taking my time and exploring and you
know guiding you through this as I play
through the game and it's just a lot of
fun to be able to do this and see the
secrets that the developers are made for
this game in it you know it feels almost
real
I get emotional about this game it
becomes such a big part of what I do
that you know I can't imagine leaving
this ocean now even though it terrifies
the crap out of me you like it good
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching hope you enjoyed this I'll
be back very soon so thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]